zack snyder's justice league is filled
to the brim with
action drama and all kinds of crazy
superhero antics
it'd be totally understandable then if
some of the movies more subtle easter
eggs passed you by
here are the things only real fans
noticed in the snyder cut
wonder woman may be exiled from
themyscira but that doesn't mean that
the amazons don't have their own way of
getting in touch with her
after steppenwolf storms the amazon
stronghold and steals their long guarded
mother box
queen hippolyta fires off the arrow of
artemis and lights a far-off beacon
warning her daughter that danger is on
its way of course an arrow belonging to
the goddess of the hunt couldn't be
more appropriate as a way of
communicating with wonder woman
not only can you catch artemis herself
fighting the forces of apocalypse
alongside
zeus and aries in that big flashback but
guess what artemis's roman name is
yup diana artemis isn't the only figure
from greek mythology to make a sneaky
cameo in the snyder cut either
in her introductory shot wonder woman is
standing on top of a statue of lady
justice
historically the earliest depictions of
justice were based on the greek titan
themis
one of zeus's lovers if you're a fan of
fancy beverages watch out
fred and ginger coffee a high-end coffee
shop with two locations in london
has made its way to metropolis and it's
brought a very famous customer with it
if you look through the window as lois
exits the shop you can see
none other than zack snyder sitting at
one of the counters
s snyder's publicist tells insider the
director's cameo is a tribute to both
fred and ginger and justice league's
intense pre-production process
apparently the king's langley branch of
the store is where snyder would sit and
storyboard the movie
and still holds a special place in his
heart and so
the shop was recreated for the movie and
selected his location for his big cameo
the image of batman perched on a
gargoyle glowing down at the city below
him
is one of the dark knight's most iconic
poses and
the snyder cut recreates it in stunning
fashion
as you may have noticed however that's
not just any gargoyle
wearing a heavy hood with bony hands and
a skull-like face
the statue resembles the grim reaper
more than a traditional winged beast
even for gotham city it's pretty
hardcore
as it turns out it's also a comic book
reference the same gargoyle appeared on
the cover of detective comics number 682
which was illustrated by graham nolan a
long time batman artist who also
co-created the masked villain bane
as far as story is concerned detective
comics number 682 doesn't have much to
do with the snyder cut writer chuck
dixon's little yarn revolves around the
b-list batman villain kg beast and a
nuclear device
neither of which feature injustice
league although kg beast
does make a brief appearance in batman
vs superman more than anything snyder
probably just thought detective comics
number 682 had a cool cover
and hey he wasn't wrong the stone family
is made up almost entirely of
super geniuses so it shouldn't come as
too much of a surprise that they're
quite well read too
still there's a big difference between
just liking a book and
actually hanging a poster of it in your
home and yet
that's exactly what victor and his
father silas have done
as cyborg broods in his gotham city
apartment you can catch a poster
referencing friends kafka's classic 1915
novella the metamorphosis
on his wall if you've read kafka's story
the thematic parallels should be obvious
in the metamorphosis a young salesman
named gregor samsa
wakes up one day and discovers that he's
been turned into a giant insect
then struggles to adapt to his new
situation as his humanity
slowly slips away for cyborg who's
grappling with who
and what he is now that he's half
machine
it's a tale that probably resonates kind
of heavily at least cyborg gets a
happier ending
while victor ultimately reclaims his
identity and finds a new home with the
justice league
gregor starves to death after becoming a
burden on his family
the extended epilogue that caps off zack
snyder's justice league gives fans their
longest and best look at what the
director had planned for the nightmare
storyline first introduced in batman vs
superman
she was my world
and you took her from me it's not the
only taste we get of the dceu's
post-apocalyptic future though when
cyborg grabs the mother box in star labs
he catches a glimpse of the horrors in
store for earth's heroes
and as you've probably guessed that
glimpse comes with a few
easter eggs too the biggest one is the
presence of another green lantern
albeit one who has fallen to evil
superman's attacks
while he doesn't wear a domino mask in
the comics the lantern lying in the
ruins of the hall of justice is almost
certainly kilawog
one of the most popular members of the
green lantern corps
kilowog who hails from sector 674 is
traditionally depicted as one of the
lanterns who train new corps members
there are
other references in this scene too the
hall of justice itself has been one of
the justice league's most popular
headquarters since 1973
when it made its debut in the animated
show's super friends in addition the
scene in which darkseid kills lois and
turns superman evil looks like it takes
place in the bat cave's ruins
look carefully and you'll see batman's
signature red screens
and his memorial to his late partner
robin among the wreckage
looks like clark might have good reason
to be mad at bruce after
all batman vs superman and zack snyder's
justice league
borrow a few key notes from the seminal
90s storyline
the death and return of superman as in
the comic books batman vs superman sees
a genetically engineered superweapon
called doomsday kill the man of steel
also like the comics when kal-el returns
he wears a black suit decorated with a
silver version of his classic logo
although sadly the big boy scouts super
mullet
didn't quite make the cut as such you
may think that the four super suits
superman considers before deciding on
his all-black garb are references to the
four replacement supermen who took clark
kent's place after his death
eradicator cyborg superman steel and
superboy but they're not instead they're
throwbacks to superman's previous dceu
adventures
in addition to superman's classic red
and blue garb the kryptonian spaceship
contains
jor-el's bone armor the spacesuits worn
by zod soldiers
and the general's very own combat gear
the snyder cut also continues the dc
eu's so
subtle it's almost buried subplot
regarding superman's cousin
cara zorel better known to comic book
readers as
supergirl as in man of steel the
kryptonian scout ship contains a pod
that's been mysteriously opened as if
someone had climbed out
well according to a man of steel prequel
comic written by snyder
man of steel screenwriter david esquire
and jeff johns
caro was the one who landed the scout
ship on earth after another kryptonian
hijacked it killing most of the crew
snyder has confirmed that the vacated
pod was supposed to set up a standalone
supergirl movie while many viewers will
be quick to note that the bone armor
presented to call
after his resurrection looks like it's
fitted for a female body
at this point it's unclear whether
snyder's original plans for the girl of
steel will come to fruition
but sasha kaye has been cast as
supergirl for ezra miller's solo flash
movie
so you know anything can happen
after barry allen visits his father at
iron heights penitentiary he cuts
through a train yard on the way back to
his lair
take a look at the warehouse behind him
sure the name national storage
may not seem like much but it's actually
a really deep cut from dc's long and
storied history
while the company's early history is a
little complicated
what we think of as dc comics was
actually national comics publications
for the bulk of its early years
sure a badge on the covers of nationals
books used
some variant of the phrase superman dc
after superman
its most popular character and detective
comics
arguably its most famous comic book but
that was just branding
legally national comics was the name of
the game
still that didn't stop fans and pros
alike from calling the company dc
even marvel got in on the act snarkily
referring to its distinguished
competition in their letters pages
finally in 1976
comics legend jeannette khan reorganized
the company and made the dc comics name
official it's hard to overstate the debt
that zack snyder's dc films owed to
frank miller's the dark knight returns
the grim and gritty take on batman that
revolutionized superhero comics in 1986.
as in that story ben affleck's batman is
an older
semi-retired version of the character
who has become cynical and jaded after
decades spent fighting crime
in this world superman's godlike power
is just as much of a threat as an asset
too
everything is bleak and fatalistic and
violent and
while there are glimmers of hope they're
hard to see through the darkness
and so unsurprisingly the snyder cut
pays tribute to miller with a couple of
shots that could have been taken
right out of the comic during the
epilogue right after commissioner gordon
flips on the bat signal again
there's a shot of batman standing on top
of a vehicle that looks a lot like the
dark knight returns tank-like batmobile
even better cowering in its headlights
are a group of goons who sure look like
they're wearing the distinctive eyewear
that belongs to the mutants
the street gang that comes to power
after batman retires
and this is the days when one's biggest
concerns were exploding wind-up penguins
that's not all though a few minutes
later the snyder cut takes us to arkham
but not arkham asylum as it's normally
known no this time around the mad house
is called the arkham home for the
emotionally troubled
a name ripped directly from the pages of
miller's magnum opus
okay let's face it by all indicators
zack snyder's justice league isn't
getting a sequel
but that didn't stop the director from
loading his revamped justice league cut
with setups for what was supposed to
come later obviously the nightmare
sequences contain the biggest teases but
eagle-eyed viewers have spotted another
one
a pregnancy test in lois lane's dresser
hinting that the man of steel
might just have a child on the way well
at this point you can probably consider
it
more than a hint in an interview with
vanity fair snyder confirmed that this
never to be seen sequel plans involve a
super baby
and while that's been a popular idea
lightly snyder's take sounds positively
bonkers in the snyder verse clark and
lois's son would have been born without
powers
and would later get into the family
business anyway by taking over as the
new batman after bruce wayne sacrifices
himself to save the world
zack snyder's justice league can be
pretty bleak at times but it ends
surprisingly enough on a genuine moment
of hope sure darkseid is still out there
plotting and that whole post-apocalyptic
future is on its way but for the moment
things are looking up superman is back
the justice league has assembled
martian manhunter has revealed himself
to bruce wayne and
offered to lend a hand and everyone is
ready to rebuild
after steppenwolf's attack that includes
bruce wayne himself
in the dc eu bruce abandoned his
traditional home
wayne manor after the joker killed robin
and burned bruce's house to the ground
according to the last shot of the movie
however wayne manor won't stay
unoccupied for long
right before the credits roll you can
see that the stately manor now
under reconstruction as martian
manhunter soars into the sky
it's unclear as to whether bruce is
planning to move back in himself though
according to snyder and reinforced by a
scene a few minutes earlier
wayne manor is set to become the new
hall of justice
giving the justice league a new hq and
importantly
one with room for a few new members of
course it's unclear how long the new
headquarters will last but
after experiencing the epic and dark
journey that is the snyder cut
it feels like an awfully nice note to
end on
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one